[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the marauders
a group of mischievous young boys who
attended hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
during the 1970s more specifically i'm
going to be addressing the talents of
these four young boys
the quartet of boys began their studies
in 1971
the same year as severus snape and they
all had one thing in common
they were all gryffindors before the
sorting ceremony even happened
the boys hit it off and when they were
eventually sorted into the same house
they knew that they were destined to be
friends though the boys got on with many
of their other classmates
this particular group of four boys had a
truly special bond
and they eventually came up with a name
for their group they were
the marauders the boys had a lot in
common
beyond the fact that all of them were
gryffindors as they all also happened to
be
huge troublemakers if there was a rule
at hogwarts
they were hell-bent on breaking it and
they were truly notorious for their rule
breaking and
mischief making their group existed for
the duration of the time that they spent
at hogwarts
from 1971 to 1978 and after graduating
they even went on to join the order of
the phoenix a secret society founded by
dumbledore
that opposed lord voldemort they all
served the order for a number of years
however on halloween night in the year
1981 their group was completely
destroyed
never to be formed again you see october
31st 1981
marked the night that lord voldemort in
an attempt to stop
sibyl trollone's prophecy from coming
true travelled to the potter residence
and murdered both lily and james potter
so
james was dead which left three
marauders but perhaps the worst part
about all of it was that it was in fact
peter pettigrew
wormtail who had betrayed them to add
insult to injury
sirius black another of the marauders
was framed by pettigrew for the murder
of mughals
this meant that the group of four happy
boys that spent a large portion of their
childhood together
was suddenly and completely destroyed
one was dead
one had defected one had been sent to
azkaban and only one remained
remus lupin the marauders the group of
mischievous
albeit talented young boys was no more
each of these boys
and later men was massively important to
the harry potter story
and harry potter franchise as a whole
and though they suffered different fates
they were truly unique individuals with
very interesting lives
but one thing that i've always wondered
is of the marauders
who is most powerful in this video i'm
going to attempt to rank the marauders
james potter remus lupin peter pettigrew
and sirius black
by power number 4. remus lupin
remus lupin was a british half-blood
wizard born in the year 1960
like most others he attended hogwarts
and it was there that he befriended the
other members of the marauders
the marauders kept a very big secret for
remus and that secret was of course the
fact
that he was a werewolf before remiss
ever began attending the school
he was attacked in his early life by the
notorious werewolf
fenrir greyback fenrir sought revenge on
remus
father lyle and his best way to get back
at lyle
was to attack his son remus was attacked
by fenrir in the middle of the night
and though his life was spared he was
destined to be a werewolf
for the rest of his life after that
moment the marauders were completely
understanding of rumors condition
and did whatever they could to make his
life seem as normal as possible
even becoming anime guy in order to make
remus feel more comfortable
after james had died pettigrew went
missing and sirius was sent to azkaban
remus kept quite a low profile at that
point the dark lord that previously
threatened the wizarding world
had been defeated by infant harry and
there was no immediate requirement for
an opposition
to dark forces however in the 93-94
school year
we finally see remus again when he
accepts a posting at hogwarts as
professor for defense against the dark
arts
remus was a very talented wizard and
like the other murders
was able to accomplish quite a lot
magically at a very young age
among other things remus was a talented
jewelist having escaped the battle of
the department of mysteries
unscathed a charms expert having helped
to create the marauders map
a practitioner of healing magic having
effectively used the bandaging charm on
ron
a defense against the dark arts expert
having successfully taught a class on it
at hogwarts
and even an accomplished oklahomans
however even though remus was talented
he was eventually killed by death eater
antonin dolohov during the battle of
hogwarts
dolorhov was an extremely powerful death
eater one of the most powerful
and remus certainly didn't go out easily
number three
james potter james potter was a british
pure blood wizard
born march 27 1960 two parents fleemont
and euphemia potter
james was an only child and honestly a
bit of a surprise to his parents
as they were quite elderly when he was
conceived even by wizarding standards
right at the beginning of james's
unexpected arrival into the world he was
pampered by his parents
they were a very successful retired
couple with nothing but time to devote
to their beloved boy
and this abundance of attention during
his formative years
certainly had an impact on the man that
he would become james's parents had good
values
which james inherited but his early life
also made him perhaps a little too proud
and certainly very arrogant when james
began attending hogwarts he met the
other marauders right away
and they formed their group in 1971
though he is often perceived as the
leader of the group that isn't actually
the case he was just the most outspoken
of the quartet
in james's seventh year he was appointed
head boy at hogwarts
and it was in the same year that he much
to snape's dismay
became an item with harry's mother lily
evans
during his time at school james
showcased his powerful magical
capabilities
time and time again and it has been
expressed that even voldemort at the
height of his power during the first
wizarding war
tried to recruit james as one of his
death eaters like the other marauders
james was so skilled in the subject of
transfiguration that he was able to
become an animagus
at the staggeringly young age of 15
after successfully achieving this
notable accomplishment
he was able to transform into a stag
whenever he wanted
in order to accomplish such a feat it
was also necessary that james have
sufficient knowledge of potion making
as becoming an animagus for the first
time requires an animagus potion
a highly complicated potion that
requires exceptional potion making
ability
in addition to transfiguration and
potion making james was also a talented
duelist having defeated snape on
numerous occasions
and an accomplished practitioner of
charms having helped to create the
marauders map
alongside the other members of his group
however as talented as james was
he did still die quite young which is
why i'm not placing him higher on the
list
he was a massively talented student sure
but he died when he was still just a
young man
and he was easily disposed of by lord
voldemort number two
sirius black sirius the godfather of
harry potter and member of the black
family
started at hogwarts in the year 1971 a
series hailed from the powerful
wizarding family
the blacks and while many of his family
members placed an unreasonable amount of
value on blood purity
sirius did not share this same belief
many of the members of the black family
went down a very dark path
and his killer and cousin bellatrix
lestrange
is a great example of this sirius didn't
want his lineage to determine the man
that he would become
and once wisely said we've all got both
light and dark inside us
what matters is the part we choose to
act on that's who we really are
while sirius's magical development was
somewhat stunted by the extensive amount
of time that he spent in azkaban
he still ended up being a supremely
powerful wizard in addition to being
highly skilled at transfiguration and
eventually becoming an animagus
assuming the form of a black dog sirius
was also skilled at jewelling
brewing potions producing charms
producing non-verbal magic
and even occlumency sirius was
eventually killed by bellatrix during
the battle of the department of
mysteries
but it was certainly a bit of a cheap
shot if sirius was paying attention
i think that he very well could have
survived that battle number one
peter pettigrew this is going to be
controversial
i know it is but i am of the genuine
impression that peter pettigrew was the
most talented
of the marauders in a perfect world
where sirius didn't go to azkaban
and james wasn't killed this may not
have been the case and in their earlier
years
their school board days pettigrew
certainly wasn't the most powerful
but later in life i think he was here's
why
peter pettigrew also known as wormtail
was a british
pureblood wizard born in 1959 or 1960.
he had pale skin unhealthy hair that was
constantly falling out
and blue eyes to most he was considered
to be a sniveling excuse for a man
whose loyalties only lay where there was
power but in his younger years
he did sort of have friends the
marauders though peter was not as
innately talented as his friends
he did have a lot of drive and it was
with this drive that he overcame his
limitations
and successfully became an animagus
while still very young
in addition to becoming an animagus
which is an advanced form of
transfiguration
pettigrew was also versed in conjuration
another extremely advanced branch
of transfiguration conjuration allows
individuals to transfigure objects out
of thin air
and was only talked to talented students
at the newt level
the only marauder that has evidence of
being able to utilize conjuration
is pettigrew pettigrew could also brew
highly advanced potions
having helped voldemort to create both a
rudimentary body potion and regeneration
potion
as well as a polyjuice potion which he
created along with bharti crouch jr
though i suspect that pettigrew only
slightly edges out the other marauders
in terms of traditional magic i think
that where he truly sets himself apart
is through his knowledge of the dark
arts because pettigrew turned to the
dark side
he opened up a hole at the side of the
magical spectrum aside that the other
marauders
would have never dared venture into
though sticking to pure magic
is noble it certainly doesn't mean that
you're more powerful
even dumbledore has openly admitted that
turning to the dark side
opens up a whole of the world of magical
possibilities pettigrew could easily
wield
the killing curse produce powerful
blasting curses strong enough to destroy
hundreds of feet of sewer system
create highly advanced potions
transfigure himself
conjure objects out of thin air and more
was he a bit of a sniveling coward
yes but was he a powerful sniveling
coward
certainly like i said earlier if the
fate of the wizarding world had turned
out differently
and james had survived sirius never went
to azkaban
things may have been different and petty
group might not be on the top of this
list
but as things stand i think that he's
deserving of this spot
not by a long shot i think they're all
fairly close but
by just a large enough margin what do
you guys think
how would you rank the marauders do you
agree with my list
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
your wizard harry
[Music]
you